what's going on guys this is rob uh if
you guys enjoy my content make sure you
hit the subscribe button
and make sure you hit that little bell
so you never miss out on my sexy voice
okay so i want to be dangerous in
for the next week i want to try an
experiment for the next week i've
actually been thinking about doing this
for a little while and i've been trying
to find a way
to see if we can make it work so what
we're going to do for this for this
whole week is we're going to cover the
event of
fear itself and this is going to be like
a background series of videos in
addition
to the videos that we normally do the
exception of course is today because
it's sunday and so normally we would
cover x where we should be covering
x-men and green
green lantern but i've been getting a
house remodeled and all kinds of good
stuff and that one on the back burner
and i'm going to do this in stutz so i'm
kind of curious to see how people
respond to this
now fear itself is an interesting story
here's the funny thing about this so
when marvel when joker saw it took over
marvel
marvel comics in the the early 2000s as
editor-in-chief basically from 2000
going forward it was designed to like
rework everything
right and then we went into siege and
then we we had like dark rain siege the
heroic age
and then we go into fear itself and the
heroic age was designed to basically say
here's heroes being heroes initially it
was like that like all these different
characters and teams got one shots and
then you had like the actual heroic age
miniseries and so on and so forth but it
didn't last
all that long because in reality people
had kind of liked the darker tone of
storytelling like stories like civil war
secret invasion things like that people
somewhat enjoyed that the other half of
this was that by the time 2011 and 2012
came around
marvel was planning out secret wars and
so the result was that jonathan
hickman's fan i'm sorry jonathan
hickman's avengers the new avengers
picked up shortly after this and then
just started going forward with the
collapse of the multiverse so there
wasn't really a whole lot of time
to sort of restore heroes back to what
they're supposed to be quote unquote
instead it was just kind of picking up
sticking with what worked and then
eventually going into secret wars which
led into all new all different marvel
now initially what this does
is this picks up with the character of
sin now cynthia smith is the daughter of
red skull and her character originally
appeared back in captain america comics
in issue number 290
really 289 going into 290. but she was
basically this this idea that red skull
wanted an heir for himself and so with
this in mind what ended up happening
here
is that cynthia schmidt was basically
brainwashed more or less now the
original intention of red skull was to
kill her because she wasn't a boy but
ultimately her life was spared and he
started raising her to become his new
protege now this comes
after ed brubaker's captain america run
and the reason why i say that the reason
why it matters is because during that
run
that included basically the conclusion
of civil war uh the events that went
into the death of captain america the
return of bucky barnes red skull having
a
cosmic cube different things like that
but ultimately resulted in quote unquote
red skull dying and so cynthia schmidt
it was really kind of her chance to
shine and it was a way to bring her
in and have her go forward as a
potential replacement for the red skull
which of course as we know didn't work
that's one of the things you read comics
long enough one of the things you learn
is that nothing ever stays
changed forever and so in this instance
what she's done is she's allied herself
with baron zemo now what they've done
is they've discovered the book of the
skull and the book of the skull
basically housed various secrets that
red skull kept hidden
and various sources of power that he was
never able to use for one reason or
another now this ultimately leads into
them basically accessing the bunker of
you know of red skull and then once they
get in
cynthia schmidt begins to basically sort
of reveal this tale and what we end up
finding out is that in
the 1940s during during world war ii
that the red skull had essentially
traveled to a section of atlanta really
in germany but had brought atlantean
mystics to him and in turn basically
forced them to start using their various
forms of magic
in order to access a sort of super
weapon out there that would serve the
purpose of allowing the germans to
basically win world war
ii now the other half of this is the
invaders themselves because with this
going on essentially
the artifact that's been summoned more
or less by red skull has flown across
the sky and landed somewhere else
meaning they have to go chase it down
now this ultimately leads to
them basically accessing where the red
skull was operating out of just because
the fact that word had reached their
ears as strange things were
going on and the invaders were literally
jumping from like basically following
the trail of the germans and liberating
all the camps that they could come
across
and so when neymar steps in here and
ends up finding out that all the members
of
you know these various uh atlanteans
have essentially all been killed it's a
big to do because one of the things to
remember is that when it comes to neymar
he is
fiercely protective of his people as
prince is basically the ruler of
atlantis he'll go to the ends of the
earth now from here picking up with a
red skull
as well as the rest of these german
forces once they arrive here you've also
got the
uh you got the invaders hot on their
trail because by this point the various
folks in germany basically said hey look
here's what was going on with red skull
and various magics and so on and so
forth but this item had basically crash
land and
uh crash landed in antarctica and the
initial indication is that it's a hammer
because
red skull cannot pick it up he can't
lift it now this is not the hammer of
thor this is a totally secret hammer
that no one's ever known about before
and so the result here is that red
skull's response is to basically say no
one can know about this outside of us
basically if you tell anybody i'll kill
you not only that like build a fortress
do whatever you have to do but your job
is to study this thing
and learn how to use its power now the
big takeaway from this is that one
this is indeed a hammer two a red skull
basically lies to von strucker and
everybody else when he says this is
explicitly for the fear none of you guys
are supposed to know about this thing
this is not for your eyes to see when in
reality it was never moved it was never
lifted because it couldn't be lifted by
red skull or anybody else and so when
cynthia finishes telling this story to
uh to baron zemo what she ends up doing
is basically
saying like this is you know what i have
here is a map a location of where this
hammer is because you know accessing
this tomb again only really reveals
information it doesn't actually reveal
any particularly powerful artifacts
and so cynthia essentially betrays
helmet zeus and takes off to find the
hammer for herself and so at this point
we jump forward to the actual fear
itself story so again we're gonna do
this very similar to civil war
since you've got the the tie-ins and
you've got like the main event itself
now this is where fear itself really
begins to
give us what it was that joe casada and
company were shooting for in the sense
that like civil war
it was designed to be a reflection of
the of the modern day now this is in
2010 2011 and so we're talking about
right before the point when like housing
prices after the mortgage crisis had
reached bare bottom when it
basically like dropped off to the lowest
point and then began the point of
recovery and so what you have here are a
lot of people who are just angry right i
mean that's the nature of this while
this story isn't really political
it is designed to basically take these
political tones from the real world and
feed them into the story right like he
had the mortgage crisis in 2008
americans almost destroyed the economy
obama told the american people sorry
about your luck bailed out the banks and
that was the end of that and so
with this whole thing going forward what
you have are people who are in a state
of anger and resentment and who are
lashing out accordingly but the funny
thing about this is that steve
rogers basically catches on to this
small nuanced thing and essentially says
people are more aggressive than they
normally would be and so where he's kind
of looking at all this the initial
response is
something's wrong things aren't right
here something's going on here this also
leads to the
various armed forces tear gassing uh
protesters because as we know
uh civil disobedience is still
disobedience and so of course they're
basically all tear gassed and they're
they're you know
knocked out for a time or at the very
least subdued and things kind of return
to a state of normalcy now picking back
up with with
with sin and traveling to and out in
antarctica this
massive citadel of sorts has basically
been constructed
not only that what she says is that all
these scientists from world war ii
are currently occupied inside this place
that they've been stuck here the entire
time and they have no
no idea of what's been going on outside
in the real world they don't know the
war has ended they don't know that red
skull is basically dead they don't know
any of that stuff
as far as they're aware they're still
operating on orders from the red skull
and what they've been doing
is studying this hammer the entire time
but in the end
it's all to no avail they haven't
figured out a way to lift it they
haven't figured out a way to tap into
its power it's just a thing that's there
and they're basically doing the same
thing day in and day out and so what
ends up happening here is that sin
basically approaches the hammer picks it
up and
immediately switches over she basically
starts calling herself scotty now the
reason why is because that's the actual
inscription on the hammer itself it's
basically that hammer's name
and so where she dawns this hammer she
begins going forward saying we're going
to seek out its
you know basically its father is owner
and then go from there now at this point
this is when we start to switch over
into iron man basically rebuilding
asgard and it's actually a pretty cool
thing because remember
this comes after the events of siege
which come after the events of dark rain
so norman osborne's already been to post
right he's already been toppled been
defeated and dark rain is over he's no
longer in in control of shield but for
the most part the the purpose of dark
rain and even the events of siege was to
basically disband and to remove the
entirety of the superhuman registration
act that was basically a holdover from
the events of civil war essentially it
was the marvel comics equivalent of
somebody just sort of letting their
voice trail off it would just kind of be
something that was never really
referenced anymore kind of forgotten and
fans would eventually ask the question
what happened to the registration act
and marvel wouldn't want to have to
release a one shot or go through a whole
bunch of hoops in order to provide an
answer to that question and so in this
instance what is up happening here is is
with the registration act gone captain
america steve rogers is long since back
he's been reborn after the events of his
of his death and this basically leads
into iron man
chipping up and essentially saying while
this does seem kind of weird at the end
of the day it is people
acting aggressively that's really all it
is because all these tests are being
done to ask the question
is this some kind of external factor is
there some psychic mutant out there
that's going crazy and using their
powers is it some villain to mysterio
make it all happen
and there's there's no answer to that
it's not the actions of any one person
that push these people to the extreme
it's just that they're just really that
pissed off and so the response of iron
man basically looking at captain america
is saying after world war
ii was over what did you guys do you
guys built things you had the economic
explosion of the united states in the
1950s and so his response is to say
we need to do the same thing you have
people right now who who basically feel
like they were ripped off
left hanging what they need is to be put
to work what they need is to be able to
do something with the auspices that they
can make the world better
and so the result is that iron man says
we're gonna get them to work asgard's
been destroyed it was destroyed by the
century during siege so let's build a
new one i told them i would so let's
just start you know let's get to work on
building a new asgard
and that's what everybody starts to do
now this is kind of a background thing
instead it's basically iron man getting
out there and telling the world here's
what we're gonna do we're gonna rebuild
the entirety of asgard now the reason
why this matters
is that for those of you guys who are
reading thor comics right now
what you'll notice is that there's two
asgards there's basically old asgard
which also exists in the dimension of
asgard then there's asgardia which is
hovering out there around saturn
somewhere the one that surrounds saturn
that's the one that iron man built and
so again with with scotty traveling down
to uh where this particular being is
located at she basically starts facing
off against all these various monsters
and demons that have been placed there
by odin as kind of a measure of
protection now when it comes to
asgardian magic
it gets a little iffy it's really a plot
device more than anything else
captain america might be able to
overcome asgardian magic in one story
and then he's just hopelessly powerful
powerless against it in another story in
this instance these kind of beasts and
monsters being placed here we would have
to believe our most likely beings
that none of the superheroes would be
able to successfully defeat on their own
and so that's why scaddy's here is
because she's going through and
literally tearing them limb from limb
using this hammer ripping them apart
only to find out there's basically a
kind of sarcophagus with a seal of sorts
on it and when she
penetrates the seal and enters into the
inside into the sort of you know tomb
more or less she's met by the arrival of
a guy who refers to himself as the
all-father saying that like he's the
rightful ruler of asgard so it's a
pretty cool thing because when that
happens odin basically says
this is it this is the prophecy that
i've been trying to avoid for all this
time the serpent has finally made his
return and so it's interesting here
because when thor comes along and
basically starts conversing with his
father the two of them start getting
really really aggressive because thor's
idea is
look we should be standing next to the
earthly superheroes who are looking to
try to find a way to
rebuild asgard for odin it's really more
pride than anything else and that's
always been the thing about his
character the way that odin's been
written marvel comics
has always been that he's exceedingly
prideful in the sense that he's like
asgardian business as asgardian business
and we do not air our dirty laundry but
for thor
he's walking the middle of the road he's
an avenger on one side and an asgardian
on the other and when the point when the
question was asked
earlier which one would he choose as
guardians or man he chooses man and so
the result here is that he's kind of
taken a stance against
odin now where thor pops up with mjolnir
and it's just kind of like look if
that's how you want to be then we can
take this to the mattresses and i can
be the hell out of you with the hammer
it's basically odin responding by saying
hammer drop
do not allow thor to lift you now it's
small things like this
that really go towards the idea of thor
becoming unworthy when thor
first lost the ability to wield his
hammer not only could thor not lift it
odin couldn't lift it the hammer had
basically had a will of its own it was
doing its own thing now of course we
know the answer to that now but at the
time
at the time we didn't and that was the
nature of the hammer in response to
how the asgardian mythos functioned that
while it was the hammer the thor wielded
it was it was basically
passed on to him by odin and the
enchantment that odin placed on it was
that only a worthy person could wield it
and so the response that odin makes is
that he gives and he takes away and so
basically
it's one of these things by the grace of
me goes your ability to wield that
hammer and it's
a significant moment because it shows
just how much more powerful odin is
than thor regardless what ends up
happening is odin basically says
we're departing this place we don't need
humanity's aid we're leaving this place
and we're going back to asgard and so
again
it's interesting because switching back
over to uh to scatty
and with this this guy basically the
serpent her response is if what you're
looking to do is topple the asgardians
and essentially conquer the world is
this something that can be done by us
and the the response he gives is
it will not just be us it's going to be
those who i deem to be worthy and so
what he does is he basically summons a
handful of hammers which are going to
land in different places
on earth and various people are going to
pick them up and they're going to become
the worthy basically the followers of
of the serpent and in turn like be
imbued with all new levels of powers
each one representing a different facet
of what the serpent stands for and so
while all this is going on essentially
earth is
is under siege by hidden asgardian
powers that no one really seemed to be
aware of before outside of odin and in
the moment when they could use the help
of the asgardians they leave odin
instructs
all of them to walk away and so they're
all basically being taken back to asgard
thor himself is being forced back there
and earth is being left to the defense
of the superheroes who were there and
that's really about it
so we are continuing on with fear itself
and uh
yeah fear it is a really cool story it
is a pretty badass story and this point
we pick up with journey into mystery now
those of you guys who don't know journey
into mystery
originally it was like a sci-fi story it
was it was a series of like you know
science fiction mystery comics whatever
and then thor appeared and then thor was
so popular that eventually journeying to
mystery became the thor line of comics
for the most part
when journey into mystery was brought
back it basically revolved around loki
and the reason for that again came out
of siege and this is part of the things
that we've talked about in the past
where we've said that marvel does soft
reboots which is to say they shuffle up
a character they change status quo
but they don't do hard line reboots
despite the fact they need to uh in this
instance what ended up happening is that
during the events of siege on asgard in
thor issue number 617 which was actually
part of the aftermath of siege we ended
up discovering that what loki had done
is he had gone to hella who was
basically the ruler of the asgardian
afterlife and it essentially like
bartered things so that he could
basically return to life when his
physical form died and so what ended up
happening after this was that in thor
617
loki came back but he was a little kid
and he had no knowledge of anything he
had done when he was an adult he was
basically a blank slate so again
it was pretty smart and it was a pretty
genius idea in terms of trying to rework
his character kid loki is actually
pretty cool
namely loki has discovered the internet
and it
is interesting he's basically taking
taking pictures of all these crazy
things happening around like asgard and
people are just like that's not like
like
you had to have used the lens filter
because obviously he's using instagram
but anyway one of the things to notice
here is that loki's basically being
ridiculed by one of the other asgardians
and this was par for the course people
remember him as
the trickster the bad guy the one that's
essentially brought nothing but ruin and
pain
upon asgard itself but for thor one
thing to remember is loki is his brother
and thor really sees this version of kid
loki for what he is he's not really
blinded by the things loki's done in the
past
and so the result is that he kind of
chases a few of these bullies off and
basically says hey look this is kind of
how these things go
eventually it'll pass and so it's kind
of interesting here because loki's
saying stuff like like when he
discovered the internet he's saying
stuff like i told people i was an ass
guardian and they started calling me a
troll like nobody on the internet
believes me and and and
to me it's it's such an awesome exchange
right you know because thor's kind of
like well i mean
you know loki is i am aware of the
internet and we avoid it avidly because
people on the internet
are weird like i mean not really but
it's just kind of a funny thing you know
like i like the idea of kid loki
discovering the internet but the fact
remains here that what loki ends up
doing
is stumbling upon this this magpie this
bird
and as soon as he approaches it the
thing explodes and reveals a key and
this is why journey into mystery is so
cool
is because when you look at traditional
thor's stories which is to say basically
everything after journey into mystery
and especially going from
really the the bronze age from like the
mid-1970s up to the modern day thor's
stories are pretty straightforward it's
just like thor's fighting a bad guy and
smashing things with his hammer because
that's what he does and that's what you
want to see but with journey into
mystery the way this is done is a
throwback to the old journey to mystery
stories where it was as much about like
the history and mythos of asgard and
telling stories in
an asgardian fashion as it was about
events unfolding in a way that was
interesting and so in this journey that
loki goes on he discovers this key
takes it to what's basically kind of a
an elf of sorts who
starts singing off this poem loki
listens to it realizes part of the poem
is a location he travels there
awakens a demon which immediately
explodes feeds the demon to volstag and
then listens to what volstag says which
is kind of a
or really kind of a few words of sorts
follows the the advices given to him in
the sense that it's like the the third
passage or so on and so forth
discovers a dragon which basically
explodes in front of him and kind of
disintegrates and then like speaks
at least it speaks to him in the old
tongue first then it disintegrates and
then he starts basically following these
these sage bits he reads this little
passage that says that loki went into
the void and no one knows why and that's
when he falls down into this darker
place and discovers the older version of
himself this is classic journey into
mystery thor storytelling so meeting
with his older self uh this older
version of loki basically says look like
i am here to impart wisdom on you and
i'm the reason why you exist
basically i'd barter with hell
everything that we said at the beginning
of the video and the idea was that i
would be reborn in a new physical form
now this is important because
this is not really the spirit of older
loki it's more of like a memory echo but
this is kind of an important thing
because over the course of the journey
into mystery line which we may or may
not cover
there will be points when kid loki will
meet with his older self and there's
actually points in
in the modern uh thor storytelling where
loki where kid loki will not only meet
with his older self he'll actually meet
with a female version of himself and
then the modern day loki will meet with
kid loki and the female version and his
original self so there's it's really one
of these things where because of the
steps that loki's taken
to ensure his own existence very akin to
like voldemort and the horcruxes what
this means is that there are sort of
echoes of himself that
exist out there in the marvel landscape
which can be encountered by any one of
his versions at any particular point in
time
assuming that echo has already been
created but it's basically him saying
look like i have sage advice to give you
i have bits of knowledge to give you you
have to listen to this because there is
a crisis coming
to earth and to asgard of course we know
that older loki is speaking of uh
speaking of the serpent and these are
important things to remember because
by and large loki was always considered
to be the trickster and the guy who
created mischief and that's true
but because of his experiences in
traveling around the various cosmos
because of his experience and seeing and
doing all these things
what this means is that loki has a vast
amount of knowledge
some of which is based on things he's
not supposed to know and so because of
all this he's a very
very huge resource if you can find a way
to tap into that without incurring his
wrath or you know letting him trick you
or something along those lines and
that's what happens with kid loki and
it's kind of a cool thing
because this is really marvel saying
like loki is loki as loki is loki it'll
always end up being the same all of this
has happened before and all of it will
happen again to quote battlestar
galactica that all roads lead to rome
that
no matter how many times loki's reborn
no matter how many no matter how many
times he returns to his former self he
will
always end up becoming the loki that we
always know because
that's what his character is that's what
he's about and so what this story does
is it basically segues into the the tail
bit
of asgar or i'm sorry of a fear itself
that we covered in the last video where
odin essentially like leads the
asgardians out of uh out of earth and
takes them directly to
uh takes directly back to asgard to the
asgardian dimension uh where they can
essentially go through and start
recreating everything now
at this point we kind of switch over to
the aftermath right like to when they're
actually in asgard itself and remember
like this this place is just in shambles
i mean it's been this way ever since
ragnarok it's been just torn to pieces
now again it's entirely within the power
of odin to fix it all and that's really
what he says but notice this
not everyone agrees with what odin does
and that's one of the misconceptions a
lot of people i think
have when it comes to the thor mythos is
a lot of people look at the character of
odin and they say well he's the all
father he's a leader of course
they all follow him loki and thor are
the only ones that really kind of do
what they want
not true just because odin is the all
father and the leader does not mean
everyone agrees with what he does
the difference here is that odin has
enough power to obliterate anybody and
he pretty much will
and so because of this thor basically
speaks up when a couple people start
talking about how it feels like a
retreat thor says
that's because it is because the power
that's there on earth whatever this
serpent is
is enough that it scares odin and odin
is essentially running away
and so where thor questions his father's
authority where he calls him in and says
look you're essentially a coward
is what you are like you're a weakling
our job is to protect all nine of the
realms you are hiding in
your in your home waiting for the threat
to come to you you are every ounce the
coward that you're acting as then odin
immediately has them locked up
immediately has thor like taken away and
put in chains and so at this point this
is when we start getting into the idea
of the worthy those individuals out
there who are given these secret
asgardian hammers and the first one up
is juggernaut so uh but what ends up
happening is of course you have
juggernaut going through his workout
time seven minutes is really all he gets
and then he then like while all this is
going on a hammer crash lands into uh
into the prison
and of course this is one of the things
that you that you end up finding out
those individuals who are worthy the
hammer will speak to them they'll just
hear
words voices things like that emanating
from the hammer itself and so when
juggernaut picks it up he basically ends
up becoming kirth the breaker of stone
now again this idea of juggernaut
gaining another power source in addition
to what he has
will be a major plot point when it comes
to the story this is something i want
you to keep in the back of your head as
we go further through
the fear itself event but juggernaut
with this power is is immense i mean he
just starts smashing everything in his
path
and so what ends up happening is we
switch over directly to uh steve rogers
to captain america
to maria hill to sharon carter and it's
basically like the new avengers roster
combined with what passes for what's
left of the thunderbolts and it's
essentially this idea that like all this
pandemonium and chaos is happening
around the world that these
objects are crash landing now in
response to them landing various places
around the world major metropolitan
areas are turning into
absolute mad houses things are
completely and totally going awry and so
reed richards chimes in as part of the
future foundation remember this comes
after hickman's fantastic four so the
future foundation's already been formed
by that point but reed chimes in as a
future foundation and says look
a hammer or something like that has
crash landed in new york we're studying
it at the moment but it looks like it's
as
you know it's from it's of asgardian
nature so this thing looks pretty
intense and then we switch over to the
one thing everybody wants to see
the incredible hulk
this is one of the coolest things that's
what i love about you guys everybody
loves the incredible hulk what people
love
even more is when the incredible hulk
gets something that modifies his power
what they love more than that is when he
gets somebody else's power source
specifically when he gets guardian
hammer people love that kind of stuff
but this basically takes place
after the events of greg pack's run and
really kind of the finality of that
event you know from from heart of the
monster hulk and we saw from that story
that it picked up where it really
ended with like the incredible hulk
bruce banner and betty ross red she-hulk
just kind of
jumping out and doing doing what they do
in the heat of passion and so they're
just kind of there doing their thing
but while this is going on a hammer
basically lands and the incredible hulk
sort of listens to it here's a talking
and then against betty ross protest goes
to pick it up and when he does
he turns into like the most badass
looking character now
it is not an accident for why he looks
this way while this is a totally new
design for him
it does have some hints and homages to
the time when he basically became a
horseman for apocalypse when he became
war i think it was but again i mean he's
null and he's basically called the
breaker of worlds because what in the
hell else would you call him everybody
loves world breaker hulk but again
it's kind of cool because from here we
basically pick up with a character named
titania now the character of titania
made her debut back in
secret wars issue number three the
original secret wars from 1984. the
original secret wars was a highly
publicized story
so because of that the idea was that if
so many people are going to be reading
this story then not only was the basis
of it to bring like all the heroes and
villains together
and have them face off against each
other in an effort to sell toys uh but
why not add some new characters in there
and so what we got we got a couple
different people there we got uh
jennifer carpenter who was the original
spider woman uh but then we also got
titania mary mcferrin now mary mcferrin
was not
really interesting up until that point
in fact her origin story was pretty
mundane she was raised in the suburbs of
denver she was shy she was timid and
never really had anything going for
the idea was that during the events of
secret wars before doctor doom had
stolen the power of galactus and then
eventually the power of the beyonder
what he had done was he had basically
created kind of like a super villain
team trying to recruit people to his
side
and so what ended up happening here is
that doom discovered uh mary
and another character and i can't
remember her name like vanessa
i think it was and then in turn
basically endowed them with powers now
mary was endowed with basically
super strength durability different
things like that and she was also like
grown
in size so she became a lot more
voluptuous and she became a lot like a
lot stronger a lot more muscular than
her previous version had been now after
the events of secret wars she kind of
had an on-again off-again relationship
with crusher creel which basically
became more solidified by the mid 1990s
and so by that point going forward they
were just kind of together uh but from
there like what is up happening she's
one of the people who basically seizes a
hammer for herself
it crashes she grabs it picks it up and
then she tells absorbing man you have a
hammer waiting on you and this is kind
of a big deal because crusher creel is
someone who can basically absorb various
metals and turn himself into those
metals absorb their properties
and so in turn giving him a hammer i
would argue he could potentially be one
of the most powerful now we'll find out
as time goes on but it's kind of
somewhat of a cool thing because in this
moment with all of the
all the worthy basically being selected
or a huge number of them being selected
essentially the serpent starts reaching
out to all of them and saying your job
now is to basically fill the world with
chaos to seed as much chaos destruction
and fear as you possibly can
and when that's done we'll take the next
step and that's exactly what they do
they start ripping through and tearing
things up now this fear spreads more
fear i mean the incredible hulk running
through ripping things to pieces red
she-hulk doing what she can it's
instilling as much fear as possible
because now you have all these people
with this these insane levels of
strength and power who are just running
rampant across the face of the earth and
where the avengers try to respond the
problem with this
is that their communications network is
essentially taken down when the white
house and the capital are totally
obliterated and so where captain america
kind of sends out the sos and says
avengers is a symbol there's no one
there to respond
no one answers him and so essentially
everyone's kind of scattered to the four
winds it's pandemonium
it's a worst case situation it's pretty
messed up and it's pretty rough
but it's amazing okay so we are
continuing on
with fear itself and uh here was a deal
with fear itself i kind of want to talk
about this for a second because there's
a couple things that i feel like we need
to explain
looking at the comments of the previous
videos with some of the questions you
guys had first
and foremost fear itself was one of
these stories that was designed to
rework things
marvel still had a lot of things that
had been held over from the joke asada
era of or at least his whole
idea of pushing things and making a new
direction so essentially everything from
like
avengers disassembled running all the
way up to
uh really the heroic age running all the
way up to dark range so over the span of
about
seven years or so uh there were a lot of
things that had happened a lot of
a lot of status quo changes the avengers
were disbanded they were replaced by the
new avengers 98 of the mutant population
lost their powers there were a lot of
things that went on
in marvel at the time one of the most
notable things was
the death of captain america and we'll
talk more about that here in a second
but what this story was designed to do
in a lot of ways was to take a lot of
those uh threads that had kind of been
left hanging those plot threads and just
sort of been dangling all this time
and essentially wrapped them up to
basically tie up loose ends now
not all of them were tied up and in fact
the ones that weren't tied up were
designed or were left that way for the
purpose of telling future stories later
on down the line for example you know
the formation of stark resilient which
would come later on different things
like that
but the idea here is that we initially
pick up with with captain america
facing off against you know the forces
of of of sin and really what kind of
passes for hydra but not really but
again this is not like steve rogers
captain america this is bucky barnes
captain america now the reason why i
feel like that needs to be explained is
because one i don't think i explained
that in the first or
second video and two this this event
fear itself
actually wraps that up so when captain
america died after the events of civil
war
and following that iron man i'm pretty
sure it's iron man takes captain
america's uniform and gives it to bucky
barnes and so bucky barnes becomes the
new captain america and his arrival was
met with
a kind of a it was a mixed reaction some
of the the old guard who really really
really wanted steve rogers to stay and
there were some who were the old guard
that wanted steve rogers to go and then
of course there were new fans who wanted
to see steve rogers stay and they were
old fans
or i guess new fans who wanted to see
him go it was really kind of a mixed bag
of people who wanted to see different
things but in
any event steve rogers had come back
about a year before this story took
place he came back 2009-2010 somewhere
on
somewhere along those lines and it was
of course the captain america reborn
storyline where you found out he was
time displaced they basically pulled a
batman from final crisis but then once
he made his return
there was a one-shot follow-up and it
was basically the question of who's
going to wear the shield who's going to
have captain america shield is it going
to be bucky or is it going to be steve
rogers and what this did is it allowed
marvel to spin steve rogers out into a
whole other series called secret
avengers and secret avengers basically
served the purpose of having like a
black ops team for the avengers group
but that's that's the team that steve
rogers largely led
uh and that was this whole thing what
this does is it basically removes
bucky barnes from the mantle and it
brings steve rogers back but at the
moment right now with this initial
charge going into
uh going into the u.s capitol it really
is bucky barnes leading the team now
switching over to asgard this was well
this was
this is an interesting uh interesting
situation because this again deals with
kid loki
and that's one of the things that goes
on here when it comes to the event of
of uh fear itself it was a little bit
different from a lot of the other
crossover events that you saw
in the sense that journey into mystery
was designed to provide
the back end for why it was loki was
doing what he was doing
in the main story itself whereas in a
lot of the events that go on sometimes
especially like when it came to like
secret empire for example the tie-ins
are wholly separated from the main story
itself and so you'll have like the
beginning of the of the event you know
of like secret empire for example and
then it'll split off into tie-ins and
the tie-ins will show what characters
are doing and then they'll they'll rap
back into the main event at the end and
so unless you've been reading the
tie-ins you have no idea how that
character got to where they were with
this
it's totally different fear itself was
designed to be kind of like a new age of
storytelling when it comes to crossover
events it was basically this idea of
like the main story gives you all you
need and you don't really need anything
else but you go read civil war and it's
it's woefully incomplete if you don't
read the main or if you don't read the
tie-ins nothing really seems to make
sense and
and so it's it's one of those
interesting scenarios but nonetheless
kid loki showing up here is basically
for the purposes
of breaking thor out of prison what kid
loki's been doing so far has basically
been trying to
sow revolution within the asgardian uh
landscape the problem with this is that
under under most normal circumstances
people may have been inclined to side
with him if it wasn't him if it wasn't
loki if it was thor
people would follow him they would it
would basically be thor leading a revolt
against odin which isn't really
something thor would do but with kid
loki he definitely would the problem
with this is that again kid loki's got
the reputation of loki and so everybody
would look at what he's saying
and essentially coming along and being
like look odin's kind of lost his mind
we've got to find a way to stand up to
him we have to go back to earth and we
have to protect it they would look at it
as some kind of ruse and so nobody
really trusted loki and so at this
moment it's just kind of coming along
and saying okay look we've got a free
thor like we got to get thor out of here
and get thor back to earth and so in the
interim what this does is it picks up
with uh really this kind of calamity
across the board in the sense that
absorbing man basically has the powers
of thor the incredible hulk now has the
powers of thor i mean it's it's
all these crazy situations and in
response to the incredible hulk what
this ends up doing is bringing in like
carol danvers
spider woman jessica drew which i don't
even know why she's there here's the
funny thing so jessica drew
has the ability to emit pheromones that
will not really have this the exact same
effect as purple man she can't really
dominate the wheels of others but she
can make them fall in love with her now
she tried it on wolverine in fact myself
and salad comic pop were having the
school conversation i called him up but
we ended up getting like he ended up
talking about jessica drew about
spider-woman and he was like well
spider-woman tried her pheromones on
wolverine and all it did was make him
dizzy so people with healing factors can
combat it but they're not like totally
immune to it but the incredible hulk
would have to be the same way but keep
in mind this thor hulk for lack of a
better word
is basically like mindless savage hulk
but bent for a particular purpose but
all these people who are picking who are
wielding these hammers are all driven by
fear that's the important thing to bear
in mind here and the reason why
is that when we switch over to the
fantastic four with the hammer having
landed
on yancey street in new york the
fantastic four were one of the first
people to respond and to investigate now
remember while all this is going on the
world is going to pot like everybody
else is dealing with a zillion different
things but when the fantastic four chime
into the avengers and say hey look we're
investigating things
then that means you leave the fantastic
four to their devices and so with ben
grimm showing up the hammer starts
talking to him he starts hearing voices
emanating from it and when he goes to
pick it up of course he's transformed
into a mindless beast itself and just
starts ripping everything to pieces so
again every single person that gets one
of these hammers
is driven by fear and serves the purpose
of sowing chaos that's basically what
this is
and the reason why is because the
serpent feeds on fear so so long as
those around him
are feeling fear he'll continue to grow
stronger and you know
basically gain more and more power now
for thor himself where he's freed by
loki and basically meets with sif and
the warriors three
the idea of basically standing against
odin of leaving odin's odin's eye
traveling to midgard it amounts to
heresy this is a very dangerous game
they're playing because while odin
wouldn't necessarily
kill them odin would certainly like he
could banish them from asgard he could
make them mortal like send them away the
odin forces is capable of doing all
manner of different things
again it's a very dangerous game that
they're playing here and this game is
discovered when odin shows up now this
is kind of a funny thing here this is
really sort of
feeding on the old nature of the thor
comics the historical
you know publication history of thor
comics as opposed to what we would
expect with odin having previously
locked up thor
and loki breaking him out and then
coming into the situation where
thor has basically been freed and he's
talking of revolt against odin it's not
really like thor's talking a revolt in
the sense of leading the armies of
asgard against odin himself it's
basically odin walking in to his son
and his friends talking about abandoning
odin's view and traveling back to
midgard and at this point it's one of
those things where it's like a father
and a son
sons always get a lot more leeway with
fathers it's just the way it is because
it's their offspring you know parents
are a lot more lenient with kids and so
instead of like
casting thought a prison instead of
making immortal or something like that
he says fine then you will you'll have
your quest
if what you want to do is go to earth
and fight among the people who are who
are there then do that now a lot of this
stems from the fact that odin knows how
stubborn thor is
if thor says this is what i want to do i
want to go to earth and i want to fight
alongside the earthlings because
i feel more kin to them than i do to you
uh then odin's gonna be like fine
because there's no talking thor out of
it and so ultimately odin casts him out
sends him back to earth gives him his
hammer and says here you'll need this
but you've got a time frame
once the serpent's power rises like once
he gets to the point where he's
all-powerful where he sees his control
of earth then one of two things is gonna
happen either i'm gonna bring you back
or i'm gonna let you die but regardless
of what fate it is you've brought it on
yourself and so again it's kind of a
cool thing because switching back to
captain america and the capital with him
falcon black widow facing off against
sin
with all this new power it's interesting
because one of the things to bear in
mind is that when it comes to marvel
when it comes to the stories like this
oftentimes they kind of seem to stretch
the limits of cadrility and they don't
really seem to make sense and the reason
why
is because you're dealing with someone
with a formidable amount of power both
in strength speed durability as well as
of the power she wields by virtue of her
hammer and would easily be able to crush
black widow falcon and captain america
and so the question you would probably
ask is
why are these the ones fighting well in
reality the avengers were never really
they never really consisted of the most
powerful beings in marvel in marvel
comics that was really reserved more for
the x-men
the avengers were mostly just like the
bravest people you know they'll run
headlong into their own deaths but
they'll run headlong no aside from the
incredible hulk
thor the avengers usually consist of
mid-range to some of the weakest
characters in the marvel universe i mean
it's captain america what the hell can
captain america do he can punch really
hard
and run fast and throw a shield he's not
ultra strong he can't you know control
the elements i mean you can't do any of
that cool stuff the x-men can
which some people will say the x-men are
kind of broken which they are
sidetracked
think about that for a second all right
so among the mutant population you've
got franklin richards kind of depending
on who's writing the story sometimes
he's a result of the cosmic control rod
which is basically
galactus power the power cosmic from the
negative zone uh or he's a mutant all
right you've got storm who's
pretty much a mega level why the hell
haven't they confirmed it you've got
magneto you've got emma frost you've got
matthew maloy i mean you have like all
these super powerful omega level
characters who are just broken as hell
like do the x-men are so broken somebody
make an argument in the comment section
somebody create an argument and and tell
me
why the x-men are not op and broken if
if you can make a convincing argument i
will give you a rob core ring so moving
on
[Laughter]
from our little rant our little diatribe
uh of course sin takes it to captain
america and that's the important thing
to remember captain america is kind of
like the leader of the group right like
he's like the moral support
if you take him down then every most
everybody else will lose their
moral backbone she ends up ripping off
the arm of bucky barnes plunges a staff
right through his chest
and essentially seems to kill him and
that's really the end of him like that's
the end of bucky barnes you know at this
point he's just kind of like look you
have to tell everyone
this serpent is is literally the person
behind this because at the moment they
haven't known
the avengers haven't really known who's
behind this all they've known is that
these artifacts which they learned were
hammers had crash landed on earth
different people had picked them up
they've
gained insane levels of power and
they've just been attacking cities by
having contact with the hammer itself
he's learned the hammer secrets and the
hammer secrets are that it's basically
the serpent who's behind all this who's
waging a war against earth and
eventually seeks to set his sights on
asgard
and retake the throne okay so continuing
on with fear itself
uh at this point we pick up with well
basically with the
the arrival of thor with thor showing
back up now here's a funny thing thor's
showing up here after being kind of
banished but not really from asgard
once he shows up here he immediately
arrives in broxton oklahoma now again
for those of you guys who are not really
familiar with thor comics broxton is
basically where he rebuilt asgard
the problem with this was that the war
of of dark rain essentially
came on the doorsteps of broxton to
asgard proper and left the city in
complete and total disarray so no one
here
is too happy to see thor you know
everybody's not too happy to see him
they're kind of like man get out of here
like we really don't want to see you or
your problems
go away it's kind of like my
ex-girlfriend you know just get out of
here i'd rather not see you
like for the rest of my life and so
because of this uh thor ends up just
sort of making his way back to the west
you know to where the rest of the
superheroes reside but what this does is
this transitions over to the serpent
himself
sort of talking about what's going on
now it's not a great big huge long
explanation but one thing that we're
going to kind of do here is we're going
to cheat a little bit we're going to
sort of
cover this and then the next part and
then we're going to like we're basically
going to skip over the unkenny x-men
and then come back to it in the next
video that we make so we're going to
cheat a little bit
uh you know we're basically going to
kind of you know skip over the part of
unstoppable juggernaut i kind of think
don't think we should but we're going to
and in the next video we'll we'll cover
that bit but in the event with
everything unfolding the way it is the
serpent really just kind of gives us a
synopsis of what he's done so far which
is to say
what it is that he's shooting for and
all he's doing is powering himself by
fear and that's the whole basis that's
one of the things
about normal humans in marvel comics in
marvel comics when it comes to average
everyday people it's usually
they're like the most annoying part of
the story because by and large they just
get really scared and run away but
that's really the big the big thing that
happens every once in a while like a
person might step up but by and large
they just kind of run and hide and let
the superheroes do all the heavy lifting
and so in response to this
with humans being so so really so timid
in relation to like the greater universe
out there when a being of significant
power shows up
they react with fear and that feeds the
serpent at the same time
odin is basically not really rebuilding
asgard but essentially having the the
wheels of war pro
prepared having the asgardians get to
work on building more weapons different
things like that now in reality
one of the things that people would ask
is why aren't the dwarves doing this
and and truth is probably just to kind
of push the story the dwarves were
really some of the crew some of the
greatest
you know weapons masters and the
entirety of the marvel universe i mean
that includes like every everybody the
dwarves make some of the best weapons
and so where odin is going through and
creating weapons
similar to that this is an asgardian war
so it makes sense that asgardians would
be the one to build these things so
that's really what's kind of going on
now at this point we transition to the
aftermath of the death of bucky and it's
kind of a cool thing because we end up
meeting up really with classic nick fury
now of course
classic nick fury is always alive
because he's classic nick fury why
wouldn't he be but well the question
sort of asked
what is this this happening here and and
what's this serpent being
that you know bucky had basically talked
about thor arrives and chimes in and
simply says the serpent is a being that
really only odin knows about and is
known about for quite some time now
something i want you to notice here is
that thor just kind of takes it with a
grain of salt he just sort of throws it
out there because by this point it's to
be expected especially when you're thor
and you're dealing with things like this
it's par for the course odin doesn't
tell the asgardians everything and it
kind of makes sense because he has
guardians are like children for for odin
you know you don't tell your child
everything because your child doesn't
need to know everything and so it's much
the same way when it comes to
thor and odin and the rest of the
asgardians odin houses a lot of secrets
and those secrets are really just
his to keep and to let them out if time
permits or if he wants to and so with a
situation like this thor knows enough to
know the serpent is a very very old
enemy of asgard but that's really about
it but the bigger thing he hits on here
is that the serpent is fighting with the
full might of
what's basically asgardian power behind
him the longer he stays here the more
people are terrified the more powerful
he will become until eventually he
returns to 100
full strength and when that happens it's
going to be difficult for anybody to win
and so
what we end up doing is basically
picking up with steve rogers he's kind
of been kept in
in the background the whole time and
he's brought back out basically redone
the captain america uniform and his
business as usual now with him it's kind
of chiming in and saying look okay where
do we stand with everything and he's
given the whole rundown of everything
that's happened so far but steve rogers
response is okay well we have
to act we have to do something if we do
nothing the serpent will continue to get
stronger the serpent's power developing
and expanding is not a result of the
action of the avengers or the superhero
community it's a result of fear so if
they do nothing they'll basically be
sitting on the sidelines while the
serpent gets more and more powerful
because of this uh with the serpent
drawing his energy and feeding on it
more and more
ultimately he finally reaches his quote
unquote final form if we had to give it
that that depiction and it's basically a
very young guy and so it's kind of cool
here because
this dude is wielding an insane amount
of power i mean it's it's crazy how much
power he has to give you perspective
when captain america alongside the
mighty avengers and the the you know
what's left of the regular avengers when
they all show up here
they're basically doing their best to
fend off as best they can but they don't
really stand much of a chance now for a
second i want to sidetrack and i want to
pick up with with iron man now iron man
being here is actually kind of funny
because he shows up to like the old
ruins of asgard what used to be asgard
and brock's
uh brockton oklahoma and summons odin
now that's one of the important things
to bear in mind here in marvel comics
it's entirely possible for anybody on
earth to contact odin whether odin will
respond or not
is totally up to him that's one of the
things to bear in mind the idea of the
of of earth you know of earth kind of
being divvied up among these various
deities more or less these godly beings
is somewhat of a misnomer all the
various godly beings that exist in real
world religion
exist inside the marvel universe and you
can talk to any of them i mean you can
you can try to contact any of them you
can contact zeus you can
contact odin if they want to listen to
you if they're willing to give you
you know any measure of attention if
they'll give you an audience will listen
to you if not then they won't and so in
this instance iron man shows up and just
screams out the name of odin and
basically what happens is he gets drunk
and then starts yelling at odin that's
basically what happens here you know
it's kind of interesting because in
order to get the attention of odin it's
not really a sucker it's like you have
to go to an altar sacrifice a goat and
then you know dance around nine times
say a prayer and then odin will respond
it's one of these things where it's like
if you're worth listening to then odin
will listen to you and
where where iron man starts talking to
uh starts talking to odin it's kind of
interesting because his response is i
didn't actually expect you to answer
but the funny response that odin gives
iron man is basically saying but like
you're a friend of thor
like like you are one of thor's
teammates as part of the avengers it's
the only reason why i'm talking to you
right now and so it's it's interesting
because
with tony stark basically being drunk
and just yelling at odin
uh one of the like what he starts to
talk about is the idea of how odin is
leaving the entirety of earth
superheroes to fend for themselves and
odin
interprets this as iron man saying i
want you to give us your armies like i
want you to give us asgardians to fight
on our behalf or to fight alongside us
so we can protect the earth but odin's
interpretation is entirely wrong and
iron man picks up on this when odin just
kind of look this is i mean sure this is
our fight but like we're mustering our
forces here
we'll fight the serpent once basically
all you guys are dead there's nothing
left and then we're going to obliterate
the entirety of the planet earth but
iron man's response is
no that's not what i want i don't want
you to fight on our behalf
i don't want you to to you know fight in
our stead we don't want you as guardians
to pick up the slack force or anything
like that what i do for a living is i
make weapons like i am
exceedingly good at making weapons i
don't want access to your soldiers
i want access to your workshop i want to
blend asgardian
you know technology with stark tech
that's what i want to do i want to
create a whole new slew of weapons
designed to use your power with my power
and destroy the serpent and so it's
actually pretty cool and
it's really awesome because it's
basically iron man developing you know
asgardian
slash stark technology uh using you know
his own
ingenuity and so on and so forth and
it's entirely possible i mean it's one
of those things where it's not like this
is unfamiliar territory to iron man it
is to a degree but he's been a friend of
thor for so long that he's well versed
and essentially just like navigating the
waters of
using asgardian energy where the very
use at the very least understanding how
it works i mean he's made anti you know
and he's made like thor buster suits in
the past so it's not entirely you know
something that he's entirely unaware of
but at this point we end up having thor
who had basically faced off against the
serpent and he was able i mean wasn't
really able to hold his own but he was
enough of a challenge
the serpent saw him as somebody that
could potentially get in the way and so
what he ends up doing is having thor
face off against uh ben grimm
and the and the incredible hulk now thor
fighting against ben grimm is
pretty quick and to the point i mean
he's defeated pretty fast and it's kind
of interesting thor literally throws his
hammer and summons it back
and sums it back to himself and it
punches a hole through ben grimm much
like you guys probably saw in the story
of infinity when thor destroyed a
builder but then he turns his attention
to the incredible hulk and this
fight is hardcore i mean it is an
absolute
brutal brutal intense fight i mean it's
it's it's
balls to the wall and it's cool to see
because with these two guys you know
tearing through each other it's
literally blow for blow
punch for punch hit for hit but one of
the things that thor says and this is a
very very big thing one of the things
that thor says is i can't beat you like
i know for a fact
i've never been able to beat you and the
incredible hulk's response is i always
knew that like i always knew that was
the case and that makes sense i mean the
incredible hulk strength is limitless
thor's strength is not so just by
logic and reason we know that thor would
not have been able to to defeat the
incredible hulk i mean in my mind
i think it really comes down to the
superman versus incredible hulk style
fight right like
that's one of the big debates can
superman beat the incredible hulk yes
unless the fight goes on long enough and
then the incredible hulk will just be
too strong for superman and then
superman will be defeated but like at
the outset
maybe he can maybe he can't i don't know
it's probably a wash i don't really care
enough to argue the point but with thor
it's much the same way you know if thor
nips it in the bud right off the bat
maybe he can win maybe he can't i don't
know it's a crap shoot i mean they've
there's been fights where thor's one
there's been fights with the incredible
hulk's one it really just comes down to
which character you like the most but at
the end of the day
with this battle between the two again
this is also taking place at the same
time that everything's going on with
like the serpent and with with captain
america
and so on this is kind of a big moment
here in fear itself and the reason why
is because when the serpent finally
arrives when he basically you know
picks up on the scene you have like the
avengers you know spider-man
spider-woman all that kind of stuff luke
cage and so on who who
try to combat him and they all get dealt
with quick fast and in a hurry i mean
they're
they're they're taken out right off the
bat they're not killed they're all just
basically knocked out
right off the bat and in turn captain
america throws his shield to the serpent
and the serpent breaks it in half now
this is a very very big thing
because the only time we've ever really
seen this happen is one if
it's a person with reality warping
powers or two thanos with the infinity
gauntlet we've never seen a person by
sheer strength alone
shatter the shield of captain america
that's never happened before and that's
a pretty big deal
the problem with this is that in reality
the event of captain america's shield
being
shattered the way it was during infinity
gauntlet really kind of overshadows this
because the event was so significant but
essentially what's going on here is the
serpent has single-handedly dismantled
the entirety of the superhero community
and this is kind of etching and stone
that when the incredible hulk's knocked
out into space by
by hulk i'm sorry by thor when he's sent
flying you know into the atmosphere and
falls back down again that it's really a
stopgap measure that's all this has ever
really been
a stopgap these guys are nothing more
than just you know bubble gum on a
leaking wall
sure it stops it temporarily but it's
only a matter of time before the
pressure builds up and that that bubble
gum gets blown out of the way and that
small leak turns into a full-blown flood
so that's exactly what's happening here
they're just kind of
in the way at the moment they're really
more of a nuisance than anything else
and that's basically what happens
captain america chiming into hawkeye
basically saying like we have to stop we
have to stand down and when the question
is asked why captain america says
because we're gonna lose like look at
around you look around you at everything
you've seen
like thor's defeated the avengers are
getting wrecked to pieces you know the
incredible hulk is a bad guy
juggernaut's a bad guy the serpent
shattered my shield with his own bare
hands like we're facing off against the
force we could not
possibly hope to defeat on our own and
so it's not very often you see captain
america do that in fact i've only ever
seen captain america turn tail and run
twice
this is the this is this is one of those
times the second time was age of ultron
when ultron raised the entirety of earth
and captain america had just kind of
given up he was like there's nothing we
can do until he realized until he
he thought of doctor doom's time
platform and so and you know with those
things in mind
fear itself is an amazing story because
it's basically like pushing the
superheroes to the brink it's presumably
the end of all things
okay so we are finally getting back into
fear itself and
we're really covering in this part like
the one tie-in that everybody cares
about really i would say the one part of
the story
that most people care about which is the
uncanny x-men tie-in unstoppable
juggernaut so
it's it's kind of funny in these
crossover events that marvel will do
there'll just be segments where people
are just like so i don't care about
anything else that happens but i care
about like that one thing
because it's cool like like that's okay
at the end of the day that's really all
comics boil down to just the cool
moments like that's that's really it
like i could cover the entirety of like
chris clareman
chris claremont's x-men run but there's
only like a handful of
super cool things that anybody would
really care about so like it's one of
those interesting things like comic book
events and all that kind of stuff but in
the event switching over to the x-men
this is all post utopia now for those of
you guys who are familiar with this
bear with me while i went over this for
the guys who are not uh utopia in the
x-men landscape was basically after the
events of decimation right like the
scarlet witch took away
98 of the mutant powers population and
then you had an event called dark rain
so so you had like secret invasion where
scrolls basically invade
the entirety of earth in the marvel
universe they start replacing
superheroes and so what ended up
happening
is deadpool had actually sent
information to the superheroes on how to
defeat the scrolls and then norman
osborne
intercepted the information and then
used it to win and so uh yeah and so
that goes into
tony stark being removed as director of
shield norman osborne becomes the new
director he disbands shield creates
hammer
and then he starts dark rain and so in
order to like consolidate his power he
basically started trying to get rid of
like all these different groups but then
you have like the x-men and at the time
the
x-men were still living in westchester
i'm pretty sure and they were recovering
from the events of decimation
but realizing that norman osborne would
seize the opportunity to basically oust
them what they did is they left the
united states proper that is to say the
continental united states and they took
up residence on an island off the coast
of san francisco so technically speaking
they were outside of the us government's
jurisdiction but not really and they
were still considered to be part of san
francisco now the way that this happened
was actually by way of this chick uh
sadie sinclair she's basically the one
who invited the x-men to stay in utopia
in san francisco he was kind of like a
friend for the x-men but not really uh
she appeared in like 15 issues so she
never really had like any meaningful
role but with the x-men residing in san
francisco and being on good terms with
sadie sinclair they basically brief her
on what's going on so far and one of the
things
that's really pointed out here and this
is pretty important is this established
that juggernaut is insanely powerful at
this point
multiple times over than how he normally
is because when he has the crimson gem
of sidorak as we know the inscription
goes you know whosoever
touches this gem or possesses this gem
xiao possesses the bands of the or the
power of the crimson bands of sidorak
henceforth you who reads these words
shall go forward forevermore a human
juggernaut paraphrasing uh when it comes
to
to that level of power he's already
unstoppable in his own
right it's one of those things where
like once the juggernaut starts moving
nobody can really stop him and he's
invulnerable to pretty much
every form of physical harm the only way
to really defeat him is to remove his
helmet and then use a psychic attack or
something along those lines
because even with this helmet gone
conventional weapons still wouldn't work
he'd be bulletproof they would just
bounce off him and so when it comes to
something like this
what this does is it amplifies his power
even that much more and so it's
basically the power of the juggernaut
with asgardian tech and
it's insane what he's capable of not
only that he's basically amassed a whole
bunch of followers and this is really
done
more for like a ransom act in the sense
that earlier what has essentially gone
on or at least what happens here is that
when the x-men launch the initial attack
it's really more of like
testing to see what they can and can't
do because they don't really know what
kind of power the juggernaut has
since it's been amplified and so when
cyclops and companies show up it's the
testing ground they grab colossus they
grab
kitty pride they go through and they say
okay look like we've got to find a way
to defeat this guy
and it kind of works for what it is but
initially this this initial skirmish is
disastrous because like all the x-men
are absolutely rare i mean they're
they're decimated cyclops is manhandled
with
no real effort on behalf of juggernaut
iceman is taken out in the blink of an
eye and these are some omega-level
characters and so with none of them
really being able to stand alone against
uh against juggernaut cyclops
essentially calls in and says okay look
we have more that we have to do here so
this of course leads to the arrival of
magneto and it's one of the cool things
because you would expect magneto to be
able to
slow down juggernaut or something along
those lines but after all he is wearing
metal so why not just lift him into the
air
but with the enhancements offered by the
serpent this basically makes juggernaut
and his weapons
immune to the powers of magneto and so
where magneto stands up and essentially
tries to like you know block or i guess
catch the hammer of
of juggernaut when he throws it it just
keeps moving towards him ultimately
it takes kitty pry jumping in the way
phasing magneto so that the hammer will
pass right through him otherwise it
would have killed him and this basically
means that like there's no real way for
the x-men to stop him that juggernaut
truly is
unstoppable at this moment in time and
so what they do is they basically say
we need hope summers now calling hope
summers in is no small thing but you're
talking about a character who has the
ability to duplicate the powers of
anybody around her with no
upper limit and that's what she does she
literally goes through and starts
tapping in to the power so she's it's
basically
a mutant with the powers of a thousand
x-men or i guess really like a you know
a couple hundred x-men who in turn is
facing off against juggernaut and notice
this
she does it by the skin of her teeth
what she ends up doing is seizing
control of his helmet
and then basically melting his helmet
and pulling it off and that's all she
can do because the sheer number of
powers she's absorbed has been entirely
overwhelming now what this does is it
allows emma frost to basically use
cerebra and then tap into the mind of of
uh juggernaut and notice this this is
one of the funny things emma frost is
very cavalier in how she does this right
she's like okay you know his helmet's
gone whatever you know i'll just use my
my telepathy that's you know amplified
several times over and then just you
know shut his mind down or something
along those lines it doesn't work
not by a long shot her psychic mind is
effectively like
fractured and and destroyed like it's to
the point where she's actually thrown
temporarily into a catatonic state
because she cannot begin to understand
the sheer amount of
energy like psychic energy rage fear
anger the whole nine yards that
juggernaut
juggernaut is putting off at the moment
it's way more than she knows how to
handle and the juggernaut moves
forward and so at this point it's a
matter of kind of running a conflict on
two fronts for cyclops again as leader
of the team
one part is getting information seeing
if there's a way to defeat him and the
other part
is basically creating a stop gap measure
and so what they end up doing is they
end up traveling to meet ileana rasputin
now ileana rasputin is currently locked
up in the in a brick inside the
i guess the x-brick is what it's called
and the reason for this is because
shortly before this story
there was essentially the return of
legion and the reason why the return of
legion had happened
is because it was basically the
purgatory uh was it project purgatory
saga and it was this idea
that after the events of inferno which
is a way old story that took place in
the 1980s when gene gray's cloned
madeleine pryor had launched an attack
on new york by unleashing demons from
this you know from basically like the
netherworld another realm basically
where iliana rasputin draws her powers
uh what project purgatory ended up doing
was realizing this was a power source
and so what they started engaging in was
was what
what amounted to like gene splicing
splicing the genes of mutants with like
demons and then kind of trying to create
their own army of sorts but what
happened was iliana rasputin had
realized what was going on and the power
that was available there and essentially
brought legion in from a different
dimension
and basically brought him back to life
but because legion is so mentally
unstable because he's so insane he's a
credible threat to everyone that like
his powers to warp reality are
extreme so with this kind of a thing in
mind iliana rasputin was basically
considered by cyclops to be a credible
threat to the mutant community so she
was thrown in the brick and so seeking
out this information and asking her
questions she basically says look i can
study this and i can take you to where
you need to go but you're gonna have to
let me out of the cell in order to do it
so it's a dangerous game that's being
played
something else is going on here what we
end up doing is kind of sidetracking for
a second
and picking up with some of these forces
who are trying to stop juggernaut and
none of it's working you know like you
have you have pixie who's creating like
portals trying to get him to different
locations and he just walks right
through as if they're not there you've
got rogue who tried to like absorb the
power of the juggernaut way more than
she could handle and she ended up
shutting down
no one can stop him and so what ends up
happening is they end up taking ileana
rasputin basically out into the middle
of nowhere she creates a portal and
transports everybody but cyclops to the
realm of sidorak
now this is where things really get cool
so sidorak is one of the elder demons
that existed in the marvel universe way
way back in the day and was
was one of the people who retreated he's
also part of the octescence the
octessence was a group of super old
entities that existed
in on earth in the marvel in the marvel
universe and the idea was they had a
contest over which one was the most
powerful and so what they ended up doing
is because they couldn't really
enter the main marvel universe dimension
what they ended up doing was basically
creating artifacts one for each one of
these members of the octascence and they
were placed around earth but the idea
was that an individual would pick up one
of these artifacts and when they did
they would set the uh
set the octessan's prophecy in motion
the earth would be divided into eighths
like in
you know an eighth of the earth's
population would be an army for each one
of these
of these beings and then in turn it
would just be like a massive war and end
time kind of conflict and whichever army
proved to be victorious would show which
member of the octascence was the most
powerful and so during the korean war
kane marco picked up the artifact that
belonged to sidorak which of course was
the crimson gem but with with iliana
showing up here she plays it exceedingly
smart what she basically tells sidorak
is juggernaut is using power that is
somebody else's
now when it comes to sidorak he's very
much like the old testament god of
abraham right like i am a selfish god
and so do not use anybody's power before
me and that's how sidorak functions
that's what he is because the role the
juggernaut is playing is to serve
explicitly for the avatar of sidorak the
avatar of destruction and so learning
juggernaut has accepted the power of
another entity out there
basically means that sidorak strips
juggernaut of all of his power basically
takes away
everything that sidorak could give had
given him now it does not really mean
that juggernaut is now
insanely weak hopelessly uncapable you
know incapable of defeating anybody he's
still insanely powerful but the problem
with this is an avatar has to exist
someone has to be the new juggernaut and
so where iliana rasputin initially steps
up
what ends up happening is colossus takes
her place and says no i will be the new
host for for the crimson gym with
sidorak now this is where things get
kind of crazy too this is something else
that happens transitioning back to the
forces of
the x-men there's two major things that
happen the first is that
gambit tries to use his powers to
detonate objects by literally taking
like touching it to an aircraft carrier
that magneto is sending like sending
directly into juggernaut and the idea is
to bring the aircraft carrier down onto
him
and then gambit will blow it up it
happens and it still doesn't work i mean
it's it's
crazy like the level of power that this
guy has he's abused op
as hell but with with colossus taking on
the new power of juggernaut
it is interesting because in the minds
of kitty pride who's basically there she
essentially says like this will kill
colossus it'll
it'll kill who he was and transform him
into somebody else
and that's kind of what happens here is
that when colossus arrives onto the
scene and starts facing off against
unstoppable juggernaut one of the things
he comments on is that like he doesn't
really want to stop like he has a desire
to just
destroy things as the avatar of sidorak
you seek to destroy you seek to conquer
and to eliminate things and so what this
means for colossus is that he's
following that exact charter and so
showing up here and and facing off
against juggernaut one of the things he
says is that in this instance in this
conflict here that it's not really like
colossus is winning easily
that for where colossus is basically
unstoppable that with the power kane
marco still has he's still faster
he's still stronger he's still more
durable like he's he's still
he's still far more capable than
colossus the difference here is that
colossus is unstoppable
that's the difference that's the one
thing like colossus literally just
starts tearing him
limb from lymph because at this point it
just becomes a war of attrition that
colossus is just like this constant
force
facing off against juggernaut and
eventually juggernaut will wear out
eventually he'll get tired and he won't
be able to fight anymore
and that's exactly what takes place what
is up going on here is the serpent
realizes what's what's what's happening
at this moment the fact that
juggernaut's basically losing and a
response
whisks him away basically snatches him
up and sends them directly back over or
brings them directly back to where the
serpent's at leaving colossus in its
current form now what this does is this
goes
forward into the future of marvel comics
and even directly into like avengers
versus x-men
with unstoppable colossus it was an
attempt to change his character up to
kind of boost his popularity temporarily
and it worked it was it was a talk of
the town
like every dude every single form
everywhere was like all the time about
like unstoppable colossus can understand
what crosses beat this guy can he beat
that guy can he do this can you do that
it just turned out it just turned into
like battle
forms all the time like battle threats
everywhere you went and so it's kind of
interesting
because in this moment what ends up
happening is that following the
departure of juggernaut this really
leads to the x-men just kind of going
back to business as usual but one of the
things that happens here is cyclops pays
a visit
directly to sadie and essentially says
look if things are how they are
then what sadie had intended to do is
that if juggernaut got close enough to
utopia that what she wanted to do is
kind of take out the entire mutant
population and juggernaut in one fell
swoop now it wasn't really from a place
of being vindictive it was a practical
approach but cyclops learned this was
the case cyclops learned that ultimately
she was going to destroy utopia and so
what he ends up doing is basically
having hope summers sit outside and in
turn like take away the ability for
sadie to control her own body and says
look
this is how things are we keep to
ourselves we keep our own thanks for
giving us a home but if you believe
you're going to be able to walk over the
x-men
that's not going to happen because we
have x-men back there that can turn your
blood to mercury we have x-men that can
make you lose control of your bodily
functions like we will have them screw
up your mind turn you inside out and
make you live the most
horrid life you could ever imagine all
the while you don't realize you're just
sitting in your living room so either
you can play ball
and you can let us be or we will make
you suffer the most horrific experiences
you could ever imagine in your entire
life
and this is this is again continuing the
trend of cyclops
falling down the path and becoming
somewhat of a darker god becoming more
extreme and becoming something more akin
to a villain
okay so getting back into uh fear itself
again this is just one of those kind of
transitionary stories but for
thor it's actually pretty interesting
fear itself kind of goes into
a sort of reshuffling of the landscape
for the thor mis mythos somewhat of a
change up and again that even goes into
uh really the new mighty thor run with
with tanneris
uh and focuses on like the rebuilding of
asgard the formation of asgardia but at
the moment we're basically picking up
with like the fall of thor not in the
sense that he died but in the sense that
thor had basically been defeated or at
least fought to the point of exhaustion
facing off against uh the combined
efforts of bin grim the thing
and the incredible hulk both of whom had
the power of thor
essentially and it was cool you know to
see that whole thing take place but it
means that even thor has limits and so
in response to this the idea is earth
cannot treat thor earth cannot basically
give him
the medicine he needs in order to
survive and so they have to take him to
asgard in order to
get him the kind of treatment that he
needs but again with captain america
showing up here
this is actually pretty badass because
you've got heimdall who kind of who
tells odin look like
there are people showing up here and
captain america alongside like hawkeye
and a handful of others end up bringing
in
thor's body and then captain america
proceeds to read odin the riot act
do he do he he rips him up and down he's
like thor fix him this moment right now
and i don't want to hear any of this
stuff about midgard has to die i don't
want to hear any of your nonsense
fix him and be done with it and odin's
just kind of like left
stammering right you know odin is not
used to being so
openly defied especially by like an
earthling but that's the nature of
captain america captain america is not
really special there's really nothing
unique about him
aside from his shield but what he lacks
in basically
anything that makes a superhero
worthwhile in terms of powers he
gains in terms of his willingness to
basically do whatever it takes to win
but walking into asgard and then smack
talking odin and telling him
do your damn job is something you don't
normally see and it's cool because odin
just kind of whisks them away right off
the bat now
you know reading between the lines here
we could probably make an argument that
there's some respect from odin
to captain america the guy's got courage
and the guys got like
honor and duty and these are things that
you don't readily find out there and so
it's kind of cool because
it's one of these things where odin
could just incinerate him just wipe out
the entirety of the avengers but instead
just sends him back to earth now in
reality this is done because the plot
has to move forward i mean that's really
the reason why it happened the issue
with this is that there really is no one
left you know they're basically in a
boat this
again very akin to age of ultron where
it's like so there's like
there's like five of us here and we're
basically the last men standing there
there's there's really no one else here
that can save us now in response to this
with thor basically receiving the kind
of treatment he needs in order to
recover odin is essentially forced to
acquiesce or at least temporarily to
basically say
you were right and i was wrong you know
earth has mighty heroes and if you
really feel the need to fight alongside
them if you
really believe this is something that
you have to do then do it then take my
armor with it and so basically thor gets
odin's odin's armor and it's one of
these things where odin says look i wore
this armor when i fought the serpent and
defeated him the first time
this armor will help you now it is
formidable in its own right it does
enhance the powers of thor to a degree
but it's really more of like a
protection spell basically meaning like
the the full
bright and you know the full might and
brunt of the serpent won't affect you
in the same way it did if you didn't
have this armor in the first place but
notice this where thor is ready to sort
of be brash and run
headlong there's something to be said
about odin basically saying look
you believe you're ready but you're not
because you're seeing this as a young
man
you don't have the years or is the or
the wisdom to understand that what
you're basically doing is going headlong
into a losing battle it's the prophecy
he's been foretold you're going to die
here now something else that i want you
guys to take note of here is that this
prophecy that odin
is referring to is the prophecy of the
midgard serpent now the midgard serpent
is totally different from this version
of the serpent they're distinctly
different beings or at least in the
original intention
in which they were made when it comes to
the midgard serpent in an actual norse
mythology the idea was that in the
in the battle of ragnarok the midgard
serpent would pierce thor with a poison
tooth and it would kill him and so when
jack kirby grabbed those things and
rolled it over the idea was that thor
would basically die during the events of
ragnarok facing off against the midgard
serpent what marvel's really doing here
is they're sort of cooking the books
really if we're being honest with
ourselves what marvel's doing is they're
saying well the midgard serpent was
believed to be
you know believed to have been you know
you're oh god how do you how do you
pronounce that you're among
your mungender i think it is i'm not
really sure how how to pronounce that
but like the midgar serpent you know is
is this thing that's there but in
reality it's actually the hidden brother
of odin that's kind of what they're
saying
but the other half of this is that thor
actually also gets the odin sword and
the odin sword is a pretty
powerful artifact i mean this is one of
the few things out there that is really
beyond reproach when it comes to
insane levels of power now historically
speaking in marvel comics the odin sword
has kind of been like a multi-faceted
object meaning there have been multiple
weapons out there that have been dubbed
as the
as the the odin sword if you look at
like thor number 300 for example when
thor fights the celestials and
and just becomes like ridiculously op at
one point there's an
instance where he's wielding what's
called the over sword which is kind of
like
the ultimate weapon out there created by
odin and then of course you have like
this
as the actual odin sword in reality it
kind of fluctuates depending on what
story you're reading if you go and read
a story during walt simonsen run that
features man
man gog and i can't remember the issues
that it was featured in if you go and
you read that
that basically focuses on like man god
trying to take the odin sword and use it
to destroy asgard
it's one of these weapons that's
exceedingly powerful but it's not
immutable
right like celestials have destroyed
versions of the odin sword before but
thor being given this weapon is being
done so
because as far as odin states it's the
only thing that can actually defeat the
serpent
that is the only thing that can really
annihilate this thing you know basically
bring it to an end
the other half of this is remember tony
stark has been in asgard proper
working on creating asgardian tech are
really melding asgardian weapons
with uh stark tech in order to pass
those artifacts onto the avengers and so
what tony stark has basically done is
he's modified his own suit
using asgardian tech and then in turn
created a whole new series of weapons so
for the most part like they're going
into this battle
pretty heavy-handed the other half of
this is that with captain america
speaking to
really what's left of the avengers here
you basically got like wolverine you got
spider woman and so on and so forth it's
kind of interesting here because this is
really where captain america shines
right again there's really nothing
special about him but the fact that he's
been through so much the fact that he's
such an incredible leader so on and so
forth is one of the reasons why so many
superheroes look up to him and so when
he sort of stands among the ranks of of
really what's left and says we have to
keep fighting
where some people want to give up in the
end they don't you kind of have captain
america saying this is the last stand
if there's no one left here to fight
then this is the end of it and really
like the dire nature of the situation is
given way
when we end up seeing this instance of
captain america just brandishing a
shotgun this is really designed to be
like captain america among militiamen
captain america with a shotgun basically
looking like a poor man's leader facing
off against you know this
almost indestructible army of people
that are led by the serpent and so when
captain america basically brandishes
this shotgun
and goes to jump into the conflict what
this essentially means is that he
acknowledges the fact they all marry and
may very well die here but in the middle
of all this
suddenly the bifrost opens iron man
shows up alongside a whole bunch of
these other superheroes i guess really
the the various asgardians with the
weapons they've brought here that's kind
of a cool thing
because what iron man does is dish them
out accordingly and then say look
these are going to create physical
changes in your body your body's gonna
be modified to reflect the various
enchantments that have been put on here
by odin
you're gonna have a transformation akin
to thor and it works for what it is
because
each member of these uh really of of the
avengers wielding these weapons are able
to face off against like the heralds of
the serpent but not really the serpent
himself
that fight is really geared more toward
really really reserve more for
uh for thor himself and so it's kind of
an interesting thing because by and
large we would expect this to be a
battle that odin would fight odin is
usually hands off and the story does
really center around asgard
and and thor but when it comes to like
odin engaging in battle that only ever
really happens in like the most
dire of situations only if there's no
other choice
left in this instance thor the prophecy
states thor is supposed to fight the
midgard serpent and so that's what
odin's allowing to happen he's just kind
of going into this prophecy and calling
it a day now of course thor throwing his
hammer doesn't really do anything and we
never
expected it to and so where the hammer
basically falls back to earth it's left
to odin
i'm sorry left to uh thor to face off
using the odin sword and basically
call it a day but in this instance and
it's one of the coolest moments in the
story captain america refuses
to quit and he will not back down and so
where he's falling where the other
avengers are falling left and right and
all really seems to be lost captain
america rallies the troops yet again
and picks up the hammer of thor now this
is the first
real time that captain america has
picked up thor's hammer he's done it
before and i can't remember the exact
issue i want to say it was it was back
during walt simons run maybe even before
that but there was an instance where
captain america
in a in a moment of desperation had
picked up thor's hammer but it was
really just kind of like you know
like kind of swinging like swinging it
towards thor it wasn't really enough
where he could pick it up with one hand
and wield it but with captain america
wielding the hammer of thor
the battle begins to shift because
seeing captain america do this
really like emboldens and heartens the
various avengers even more
because it means now we've legitimately
got a fighting chance cap picked up
thor's hammer holy
that's really kind of what that means
here and so it's a really really cool
moment because turning the tide against
the forces of
of of of the serpent basically means
that like the battle is essentially
coming to an end that it's really
beginning to
to wind down here and so in this massive
conflict against the midgard serpent
some of the asgardians end up riding
into the scene uh really being led by
odin to face off directly against you
know the
the forces of the serpent but the idea
is that that essentially thor's gonna
die here which he basically does he
manages to
stab the serpent in the head using the
odin sword essentially killing him and
then in turn
falls to his own death and so it's kind
of a cool thing here because what this
does is it disperses the various hammers
of the serpent
everybody returns back to their normal
state and then odin in turn grabs thor
and takes him back to asgard now this is
kind of a big moment here because
the way that this was done all
indications was that
this was going to see the the death of
thor that thor was going to be
officially removed from the marvel
landscape that's the entire perspective
that was being put off by marvel the
issue with this is that while thor
is not the highest selling character
that marvel's ever had he is certainly
one of the most recognizable especially
now in the marvel cinematic universe and
so when you're talking about someone
like thor you can't just
kill him off right i mean you can't just
get rid of him somebody has to take his
place and so
in this instance of course now like well
at least as awesome as it was we had
jane foster which i'm still so pissed
that she's not thor anymore
but in this instance like thor would
have to return in some form or fashion
and so what this does is that in this
kind of rebuilding phase you know in
this moment when everything's sort of
being
the avengers are kind of rebuilding
everything and really a lot of the
work's being handed over to damage
control who in turn are going to start
rebuilding everything with their
government subsidies and contracts and
absolute corruption and the most heinous
of ways
what this means is that the serpent
himself has kind of been brought back to
asgard and is going to be monitored by
odin but at the same time
thor is essentially like burned at the
pyre it's basically like he's getting
he's receiving an asgardian funeral and
so the question a lot of people had is
what comes next like what comes after
this with thor being removed now this is
something that's kind of interesting
here so following this in from 2010
going to 2011 and 2012
marvel launched marvel now and what
marvel now was designed to do was kind
of reshuffle things now this kicks off
something called
shattered heroes and shattered heroes
was basically the aftermath
of fear itself and the fact that like
the heroes had basically been
forced to face some of their biggest
fears and what the mar you know as the
marvel tagline always goes and it
changed the marvel universe forever not
really but that was that that was the
kind of tagline that was basically being
used but but in this whole thing
what this did is it set the stage for
matt fraction to finish his run which
brings in tanneris i'm pretty sure it's
how you pronounce his name which is
basically ooh look the troll pretending
to be
thor or pretending to be like a like a
thor reborn character and then loki
essentially rescuing the real thor by
kind of
splitting donald blake and thor at half
again so it was it was sort of like a
like a ham-fisted thing it's really what
it was it was it was kind of kind of
like this idea well thorn
and and donald blake are still one
person all right get rid of him like get
rid of that thing it's old hat
marvel's been doing it like we've been
doing it since the 1960s just split them
and be done with it and that's basically
what it was and that leads directly into
jason aaron's
gore the god butcher story arc so you
got like six issues and then gore
that's that's really what happens here
it just kind of wraps up the tail bit of
thor
he eventually returns and that's that's
really the end of that but going into
shattered heroes things are actually
kind of cool to a degree it kind of
depends on what you're reading about if
you're really like mighty avengers
things actually get pretty badass
if you're reading just like your
standard avengers well you know that
basically goes into hickman's avengers
in new avengers run and then you go into
like you know the the you know
the whole like basically setting the
stage for like avengers versus x-men and
all that kind of good stuff uncanny
x-force i think continues on for a
little while there's a few things that
happen here and there of course this
also leads directly you know with this
whole situation between uh banner and
the hulk the hulk becoming a sort of
herald of the serpent uh this led into
the incredible hulk himself
separating bruce banner which we covered
in jason aaron's run so again
like a lot of the things that we've
covered recently within the last year or
so from like captain america and iron
man and the incredible hulk and the
avengers and so on and so forth all that
really stems out of fear itself all that
really comes
out of all this stuff so again it's a
pretty cool story and it's pretty
interesting in terms of the purpose it
serves but again it just kind of sets
the stage for things to come after this
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah i
will catch you all later
peace
you